und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers guten
Abend in allen die Bilder sind kaum zu
fassen es geht um die Zukunft unseres
Planeten die größte Herausforderung für
diese Welt und dann wird bereits
abgebaut obwohl die Verhandlungen noch
laufen die Gastgeber Räumen schon mal
Tische und Stühle Weg manche
Delegationen sind längst abgereist
offenbar war es wichtiger den Rückflug
zu bekommen als einen Durchbruch zu
erreichen so gesehen ist es schon fast
ein Wunder dass die UNO Klimakonferenz
in Ägypten überhaupt ein Ergebnis
gebracht hat es gibt jetzt zum ersten
Mal einen Fond für
ärmere Staaten das ist ein Erfolg um
Klimaschäden auszugleichen beim Schutz
des Klimas dagegen viel Frust in Sharm
el Sheikh Mac Hugo
harte Verhandlungen in Sharm el Sheikh
bis in die frühen Morgenstunden das
zehrt an den Kräften dann endlich der
Hammerschlag für die Schlusserklärung
bei
decided die Erneuerbaren sollen zwar
ausgebaut Kohle Energie schrittweise
heruntergefahren werden doch die von der
EU geforderte klare Absage auch an Öl
und Gas fehlt das aufgrund der Blockade
von einigen großen Emittenten und Öl
produzierenden Staaten überfällige
Schritte zur Minderung und zum Ausstieg
aus fossilen Energien verhindert wurden
ist mehr als frustrierend von einer
wahren Abwehrschlacht gegen die
Ölstaaten reden Beobachter bei schwacher
Verhandlungsführung der ägyptischen
Präsidentschaft und das Ergebnis ein
Rückschlag war es zwar nicht aber eben
auch kein Fortschritt
diese Konferenz hier war ein Pflaster
auf eine klaffende Wunde mit den
Maßnahmen die hier beschlossen wurde ist
es extrem schwierig die 1,5 Grad noch
einzuhalten einen unerwarteten
Durchbruch gab es aber doch ein
Hilfsfond für Schäden und Verluste durch
Klimawandel folgen in diesen sollen die
reichen Staaten die die Erderwärmung vor
allem verursacht haben einzahlen das
Geld fließt immer dann an arme Länder
wenn diese von Stürmen Dürre Fluten oder
dem steigenden Meeresspiegel getroffen
werden dennoch der hinterlässt immer
deutlichere Spuren auch wenn vieles noch
zu klären ist für die Entwicklungsländer
ist der Fond für den sich nun auch die
EU stark gemacht hat ein überfälliger
Schritt
das war eine Meisterleistung der
Europäer dass sie dafür die ganzen
Industriestaaten an Bord bekommen haben
endlich diesen historischen Durchbruch
zu erreichen nachdem die
Entwicklungsländer 27 Jahre darauf
gewartet haben dass so ein Bekenntnis
zur Solidarität für die verletzlichen
gegeben wird und dass man anerkennt hier
dass Menschen entschädigt werden müssen
für Klimakatastrophe und Klima Folgen
ist total wichtig dass man sich aber
eben dann auch in dem Zuge nicht hat
einigen können der Klimakatastrophe so
schnell wie möglich ein Ende zu setzen
das ist richtig dramatisch und das
betrifft uns alle die Details des Fonds
werden in einem Jahr bei der
Klimakonferenz in Dubai verhandelt
Streitpunkt China und die Golfstaaten
weigern sich einzuzahlen es könnten also
auch dann wieder lange Nächte werden
Professor Ottmar Edenhofer ist wieder
bei uns Direktor des Potsdam Instituts
für Klimafolgen Forschung Herr Professor
guten Abend guten Abend wir zwei haben
am Anfang der Konferenz miteinander
gesprochen hier im heute journal und ich
habe noch ihre Mahnung im Ohr von damals
wir also auch wir in den Medien sollten
nicht immer nur gucken gibt es einen
Durchbruch so gesehen wie würden sie das
Bewerten unterm Strich was Sharm el
Sheikh gebracht hat also in Sharm el
Sheikh wurde ein Scheitern verhindert es
war kein Durchbruch und es war ein nur
sehr sehr mäßiger Erfolg für das Klima
dann gucken wir mal auf die beiden
großen Punkte vielleicht zunächst diesen
Ausgleichsfonds ein historisches
Ergebnis heißt es heute die Frage ist
nur was was nutzt so ein Fonds wenn
unklar ist wer bezahlt ja das ist für
eine richtig und hier ist die Strategie
der Europäer nur teilweise aufgegangen
die wollten ja erreichen dass vor allem
China zahle wird und nicht aus dem Fond
Geld erhält das ist vollkommen richtig
das ist nicht richtig gelungen es ist
nicht klar wer einzahlt es ist auch
nicht klar nach welchen Kriterien das
Geld verteilt werden soll also da ist
noch viel zu verhandeln und man kann
sagen gut wenn die Haupt Emittenten
wissen sie müssen in der Zukunft
Klimaschäden bezahlen dann haben sie
damit auch einen
anreiz-emissionen zu vermeiden aber das
ist wirklich gemessen an dem was zu tun
ist ein sehr kleiner Schritt das heißt
es klingt einfach gut aber es verläuft
sich so ein bisschen im Sand ja na ja
wir haben ja bisher noch keine so guten
Erfahrungen mit solchen Fonds dass die
Versprechungen dann auch tatsächlich
eingehalten wurden und da steht jetzt
noch eine ein großer
Verhandlungsmarathon bevor um überhaupt
zu klären was als Klima Schaden hier zu
bewerten ist und wie hoch er zu bewerten
ist ganz besonders tragisch sieht es bei
dem anderen Punkt aus nämlich beim
Klimaschutz wir haben jetzt 40.000
Teilnehmer gesehen zwei Wochen lang
Gespräche die Ziele scheinen irgendwie
deutlich bescheidener geworden zu sein
ob das Problem ja eher größer geworden
ist irgendwie sind wir da wo wir vorher
schon waren ein zurückfallen ist
verhindert worden heißt es jetzt immer
wieder aber reicht das wenn wir nicht
eigentlich nach vorne müssten ja wir
müssten noch vorne und im Kern ist beim
Klimaschutz einfach nur das wiederholt
worden was in Glasgow schon gesagt
worden ist aus meiner Sicht sollte man
aber jetzt den Fokus darauf richten auf
dem Kohleausstieg denn dort ist in der
Tat was interessantes passiert es ist
nicht nur der Kohleausstieg bekräftigt
worden sondern es ist auch davon Geräten
geredet worden das internationale
Finanzsystem vor allem die
multilateralen Entwicklungsbanken zu
reformieren und das könnte heißen dass
multilaterale Entwicklungsbanken
Kohlekraftwerke aufkaufen stilllegen und
dafür von den Ländern z.B im Gegenzug
die Zusagen erhalten dass die
Subventionen für die fossilen
Energieträger abgeschafft werden
indonesien hat jetzt mit 20 Milliarden
einem solchen Plan zugestimmt in
Südafrika ist es unterwegs ich glaube
wir sollten jetzt nicht warten bis zur
nächsten Klimakonferenz sondern wir
sollten jetzt damit beginnen die
multilateralen Entwicklungsbanken zu
befähigen in diese Richtung
voranzuschreiten und was müssten wir
dazu ganz konkret tun
dazu müssen die Entwicklungsbanken von
den Regierungen ermächtigt und befähigt
werden und dann sind die Pläne ja schon
in der Schublade dass man damit beginnt
diese Kohlekraftwerke aufzukaufen an
klaren Ausstiegsplan festzulegen und
dann eben auch den Ländern günstige
Kredite anzubieten denn wir dürfen nicht
vergessen die Kapitalkosten in Schwellen
und Entwicklung sind so hoch dass die
Erneuerbaren sich nach wie vor dort
nicht rentieren also ich verstehe sie
richtig wir müssen eigentlich so ein
bisschen weg von diesem Fokus eine
Klimakonferenz dann die nächste
Klimakonferenz sondern uns eher mit der
Zeit dazwischen befassen wir sollten uns
mit der Zeit dazwischen befassen und wir
sollten jetzt anerkennen dass wir nicht
nur eine ambitionslücke haben sondern
dass wir eine klaffende
implementierungslücke haben und das muss
jetzt angepackt werden und dafür gibt es
zwar Anstöße aus dieser Konferenz aber
die müssen jetzt wirklich ernsthaft
umgesetzt werden uns läuft die Zeit
davon und wir können uns nicht erlauben
dass wir also bei jeder Klimakonferenz
mit Hoffnungen starten es käme der große
Durchbruch und dann endet das Ganze doch
wieder mit einer Enttäuschung der Appell
aus Potsdam Professor Edenhofer vielen
Dank ich danke Ihnen
Strom sparen ist ein Fremdwort in Katar
das Emirat liefert Energie für die ganze
Welt und ist damit sagenhaft reich
geworden heute funkelt und blitzt es
dort aber noch mal doppelt so
aufsehenerregend wie sonst mit einer
gigantischen Lichtshow ist das größte
Fußball-Event der Erde eröffnet mitten
in der Wüste mitten im Winter mitten
rein in eine Kontroverse um die
Menschenrechtslage vor Ort die diese WM
überschattet das Eröffnungsspiel haben
die Kataris verloren aber die Gastgeber
sind trotzdem stolz und nicht nur sie
zum ersten Mal hat die arabische Welt
ein derartiges globales Sport Ereignis
aus Kata Wolfgang zimmermann
dramatisches Szenen an der Fanmeile in
Doha 40.000 Leute passen hier rein aber
fast doppelt so viele stehen an
Abweisung Handgemenge Chaos nur mühsam
sichern die Polizisten ab
so viel Geld aus die haben das einfach
nicht ordentlich organisiert seit 4 Uhr
stehen wir an das ist beschämend
an der Fanmeile
Stadion dagegen haben sie alles fest im
Blick die katarische Kamel Polizei
drinnen verpassen Sie nicht Ihre
Mannschaft liegt früh 01 gegen Ecuador
zurück
auf der Fanmeile Jubelstürme bei deren
Fans
eine Viertelstunde später schon die
Entscheidung 0:2 Ecuador macht alles
klar der Gastgeber ernüchtert und bei
Spielende schon viele Plätze leer we los
wir haben verloren klar aber wir sind
glücklich dass wir hier in Katar alle
begrüßen dürfen es ist eine fantastische
Erfahrung für uns
es ist toll für mich für mein Land ich
bin glücklich dass Ecuador gewonnen hat
wir hatten auch eine tolle
Eröffnungszeremonie die Organisation war
super
auf dieser Eröffnung war die ganze Welt
gespannt wie wird sich das Gastgeberland
präsentieren nach all der Kritik
es war eine Show weniger bombastisch als
gedacht
[Musik]
US-Schauspieler morgen Freeman spricht
mit einem körperbehinderten katarischen
social media-star über Toleranz und
miteinander und dann eine überraschender
Moment
die Herrscher Familie gewährt Einblick
in ihr Familienalbum der Emir spielt
Fußball mit Freunden seltene Bilder
einer sonst Kamera scheuen Familie
danach hält er seine Rede und begrüßt
herzlich Menschen verschiedenster
Herkunft aus allen Nationen Religionen
Orientierungen
[Applaus]
ab heute Abend werden wir 28 Tage lang
und mit uns die ganze Welt diesem großen
Festival des Fußballs beiwohnen in einer
Atmosphäre menschlicher und
zivilisierter Kommunikation
ein Appell also an ein
freundschaftliches Miteinander insgesamt
eine Show die viel auf Toleranz sitzt
ich bin so stolz und glücklich so etwas
habe ich noch nie erlebt ich hoffe dass
alle die Eröffnungsfeier genossen haben
nun läuft sie also die umstrittenste WM
aller Zeiten und Kata hofft dass damit
alle Diskussionen beendet sind
ja beendet werden die Diskussion wohl
nicht sein unsere Korrespondentin für
die Region ist gulineartei Gulli guten
Abend du bist schon länger in Katar
unterwegs wie willst du denn die
Stimmung aktuell beschreiben ist das
auch ein Pan arabisches Ereignis
durchaus Stolz und Freude nicht nur hier
sondern ich würde sagen in der ganzen
Region in allen arabischen Ländern auch
stolz darüber dass diese WM endlich in
eine muslimischen Land stattfinden kann
auch darauf dass Kata sich am Ende doch
durchsetzen konnte mit seinen eigenen
Normen mit seinen eigenen Regeln und es
hat im Vorfeld auch starke Signale der
Unterstützung der Solidarität mit Kata
gegeben von den Nachbarländern Signale
aus der arabischen liga-signale der
arabischen Länder in der UNESCO man hat
immer wieder den sogenannten Kampagnen
Journalismus gegen das Land verurteilt
man hat davon gesprochen dass diese WM
unglaublich positive kulturelle Folgen
für die gesamte Region haben wird sicher
Kata ist kein keine große Fußballnation
aber in der gesamten arabischen Welt
spielt Fußball eine ganz große Rolle es
ist eine ganz große kulturelle Kraft
interessant dieser dieser Blick aus der
arabischen Perspektive jetzt hat sich
Katha diese WM ja geholt mit unfassbar
viel Geld begleitet von vier Kritik an
der Menschenrechtssituation das ganze
hatten auch in einem politische
Komponente es will gegen die
unmittelbaren Nachbarn in der Region
Flagge zeigen kann man jetzt schon sagen
ob und wie diese WM die Situation und
auch Kata selbst verändern wird
ja das hat es schon es hat Katha
verändert also wenn man sich das
Lebensgefühl hier anschaut ist es ja
immer ein bisschen so man steht im
Schatten der mächtigen Nachbarn im
Schatten des großen mächtigen
Saudi-Arabien und auch das Iran mit dem
man sich ein Gasfeld teilt aber auch mit
den Saudis mit denen man sich die
einzige Landgrenze teilt und man hat
hier immer so ein bisschen die Angst
gehabt dass einem das gleiche Schicksal
wie der fährt wie damals das vom Iraker
gefallen wurde man hat etwas ähnlich
traumatisches erlebt hier mit der
Blockade mit dem im Barcode der
arabischen Nachbarn weil die wiederum
Kata eine zu unabhängige Außenpolitik
es beschuldigt haben zu unabhängig zu
agieren Kontakte mit der Muskeln
Bruderschaft zu haben sie der Kontakte
mit Terroristen bezichtigt diese Krise
ist 2021 beendet worden nach dreieinhalb
Jahren aber es war wirklich eine Krise
die einen Krieg in der Region hätte
auslösen können und es ist kaum zu
glauben dass heute der saudische
Kronprinz und Premierminister Mohammed
den Salman im Stadion gewesen ist dass
der ägyptische
auch im Stadion gewesen ist also die
ehemaligen Gegner es bedeutet die WM hat
Sicherheit für Katar gebracht hat es auf
der auf der Welt in der Weltwahrnehmung
wirklich etabliert in der Landkarte
etabliert und das vor allen Dingen auch
eine Show der ist Selbstbewusstseins
gewesen gegenüber dem saudischen
Kronprinzen interessant auch in diese
politische Analyse goldene herzlichen
Dank dafür und gute Nacht nach Doha
online und in 3D auf ZDF heute nehmen
wir sie mit ins größte Stadion dieser WM
Hintergründe zum Bau und zum Spielfeld
sie können sich da durch Klicken und
interaktiv hinein zoomen und dabei mehr
darüber erfahren was hinter der goldenen
Fassade steckt
und was ist auch noch wichtig heute
Hannah da hast Du den Überblick die
Türkei hat dutzende kurdische Stellungen
im Nordirak und im Norden Syriens
angegriffen dabei sollen nach Angaben
der syrischen Beobachtungsstelle für
Menschenrechte einunddreißig Personen
getötet worden sein auch Zivilisten laut
dem türkischen Verteidigungsministerium
richteten sich die Luftangriffe gegen
die verbotene kurdische Arbeiterpartei
PKK und die syrische Miliz ypg Ankara
macht sie für den tödlichen
Bombenanschlag in Istanbul vor einer
Woche verantwortlich
die Kurden Medizin PG reagierte nach
türkischen Angaben bereits mit einem
Vergeltungsschlag auf die Angriffe durch
eine aus Syrien abgefeuerte Rakete
sollen an der türkisch-syrischen Grenze
mindestens ein türkischer Soldat und
mehrere Polizisten verletzt worden sein
bei Protesten in der kurdischen Stadt
Mahabad im Nordwesten Irans soll es laut
Menschenrechtsorganisationen zu massiver
Gewalt gekommen sein die in Norwegen
ansässige Organisationen hangarf
berichtete von Schüssen und
veröffentlichte Aufnahmen von
Hubschraubern die über der Stadt Kreisen
Videos in den sozialen Netzwerken zeigen
Militärfahrzeuge die durch die Straßen
fahren
in Kasachstan haben heute vorgezogene
Präsidentschaftswahlen stattgefunden und
laut ersten Prognosen konnte sich am
centaba Türkei für weitere 7 Jahre die
Macht sichern demnach kommt er auf rund
82% der Stimmen Türkei hat demokratische
Reformen versprochen neues Kasachstan
heißt das Paket dass die Todesstrafe
abschaffen das Parlament stärken und
Korruption bekämpfen soll noch im Januar
hatte Türkei jetzt aber Massenproteste
gegen hohe Preise blutig
niedergeschlagen für Deutschland ist das
rohstoffreiche Land einer der
wichtigsten Partner in Zentralasien
das ukrainische Atomkraftwerk saporicia
ist erneut unter Beschuss geraten ein
von russischer Seite veröffentlichtes
Video soll Detonationen in der Nähe und
auf dem AKW-Gelände zeigen die
Internationale Atomenergiebehörde
berichtet durch eigene Experten vor Ort
es habe Schäden unter anderem an einigen
Gebäuden gegeben die jedoch bislang die
nukleare Sicherheit nicht
beeinträchtigten Russland und die
Ukraine machen sich gegenseitig für den
Beschuss verantwortlich
mehr als 8.300 getötete Menschen die
keine Soldaten waren habe es in diesem
Krieg bislang gegeben sagen die
ukrainischen Ermittler darunter sind
nach ihren Angaben 437 Kinder und das
sind nur die gesicherten zahlen die
tatsächlichen dürften noch höher liegen
und 3,3 Millionen Mädchen und Jungen in
der Ukraine sind aktuell auf Hilfe von
außen angewiesen und dazu kommt jetzt
noch dass viele Familien nicht mehr
wissen wie sie ihre Kinder vor der Kälte
schützen sollen heute ist
internationaler Tag der Kinderrechte der
Appell der Vereinten Nationen dazu
dürfte in russlandsmachzentrum verhallen
der Kremmel lässt weiterhin ganz gezielt
die Strom und Wärmeversorgung
bombardieren dabei sollte jeder Tag
Kindertag sein und das braucht keinen
Anlass um das schwere Schicksal gerade
der kleinsten Zylindern aus der Ukraine
für die schwerkranken Patienten in der
Kinderpflege von rakif ist der Krieg
eine zusätzliche Bedrohung sie sind
angewiesen auf ständige Betreuung
medizinische Geräte und auch auf
Medikamente rakev ist von bald neun
Monate im Krieg und immer noch
andauernden Beschuss schwer gezeichnet
diese Kinder brauchen jetzt besonders
dringend hilfe wir haben alleine jetzt
in den letzten Monaten die Krankenhäuser
in der Region mit etwa 170 Tonnen an
Hilfsgütern versorgt also Dinge die wir
hier sehen in den Kartons aber eben sehr
stark auch Medikamente Verbands durch
all das was Kinder und Familien in der
Zeit hier gebraucht haben in den
Krankenhäusern und das nicht nur in den
großen Städten wie Harke den man ansieht
wie stark die Stadt und der Raketen
Attacken leidet auch außerhalb wo
russische Truppen die Gebiete
kontrollierten und erst im Herbst
betrieben wurden wie hier in balakia
brauchen die Menschen Hilfe
auch in Dörfer gebracht die bis zu 40 km
entfernt sind dort waren die Menschen
sehr dankbar denn sie haben weder Gas
Wasser noch Strom alles was Sie kochen
wird auf offenem Feuer erhitzt
sechs Monate lang haben sie weder Renten
bekommen noch irgendwelche andere
humanitäre Unterstützung
je mehr Gebiete die ukrainischen Truppen
befreien hier offensichtlicher wird die
Hilfsbedürftigkeit der Menschen die seit
fast neun Monaten im Kriegsgebiet
ausharren
in der U-Bahn von rakev die im Krieg
schon Schutzraum für viele gewesen ist
haben sie ein Kinderzentrum eingerichtet
durch den jüngsten Beschuss gibt es in
der Stadt kaum noch Strom im Licht der
Handy Leuchten haben die Kinder aber
trotzdem viel Spaß vergessen den Krieg
über Ihnen für ein paar glückliche
Momente
wir sind vor ein paar Wochen nach rakig
zurückgekehrt jetzt gibt es hier wieder
Luftangriffe in den letzten Tagen haben
wir uns nicht mehr aus dem Haus getraut
so ein Kinderzentrum ist eine tolle
Gelegenheit mal andere Kinder zu treffen
Schulunterricht gibt es ja nur online
das Kinderhilfswerk der Vereinten
Nationen hat seit Kriegsbeginn knapp 2,5
Millionen Kindern und ihren
betreuer:innen geholfen mit dem Erlebten
wenigstens etwas besser umzugehen
Bombenalarm und ausgelassen spielende
Kinder in der U-Bahn der UNICEF Mann
sagt noch diese Diskrepanz zwischen dem
greifbaren Krieg über der Erde und diese
Moment geschützter Kindheit in der
Metrostation werde ich nie vergessen
es gibt eine Frage die sich natürlich
die ganze Zeit stellt und jetzt auch
immer drängender gerade von Top Militärs
in den USA kommt wie kann dieser Krieg
aufhören Florian neuhahn unser
nato-korrespondent hat sich Rat geholt
bei aktuell handelnden und in den
Geschichtsbüchern
einen Krieg zu beginnen dafür braucht es
nicht viel eine Idee einen Kriegstreiber
und eine Armee die seinen Befehlen
gehorcht einen Krieg zu beenden dagegen
ist ungleich schwieriger
es ist der Nato-Generalsekretär der
diese Woche wieder einmal prophezeit
rückt wahrscheinlich wird dieser Krieg
am Verhandlungstisch Enden
Verhandlungen beenden Kriege haben wir
aus der Geschichte gelernt
1648 beendet der Westfälische Friede den
30-jährigen Krieg
1919 der Friedensvertrag von Versailles
den Ersten Weltkrieg und 45 der
militärische Erfolg der Alliierten den
zweiten doch da fehlt etwas im
schwedischen Uppsala haben sie alle
militärischen Konflikte seit 1945
ausgewertet
musste
Konflikten die meisten Konflikte
verlaufen irgendwann im Sande sie enden
durch eine etwas geringere Aktivität das
heißt die Gewalt ist dann nicht mehr so
brutal es gibt nicht mehr so viele Tote
aber der Konflikt ist immer noch da
ein Krieg ohne Ende eingefroren so wie
der Konflikt zwischen den ehemaligen
Sowjet Republiken Armenien und
Aserbaidschan der seit Jahrzehnten
spielt und immer wieder ausbricht
zuletzt in diesem september die Zukunft
auch für die Ukraine wo trotz jüngster
Erfolge wie hier in Hassan auch die USA
vor zu großen ukrainischen Hoffnungen
warnen
[Musik]
die Wahrscheinlichkeit eines
militärischen Sieges der Ukraine also
eine Sieges bei dem Russland aus der
gesamten Ukraine vertrieben worden ist
einschließlich der Krim die ist in naher
Zukunft nicht hoch
high der letzte Versuch den
ukraine-konflikt zu lösen war in Minsk
2015 wie man heute weiß gescheitert 7
Jahre später der Krieg heftiger denn je
der Gedanke an Verhandlungen jetzt
unerträglich meint der Europaabgeordnete
Sergej lagodinski Ende der Woche selbst
in Kiel
es ist für die Ukraine und zumutbar mit
jemanden zusammen zu sitzen und über
etwas zu verhandeln der die Legitimität
der territorialen interiorität und der
Existenz des Gegenübers also der Ukraine
weiterhin in Frage stellt jetzt muss im
Grunde die Initiative von Russland und
ausgehen und Initiative muss so sein
dass die Ukraine
und auch die ukrainische Regierung der
Überzeugung ist dass sie mit so einem
Friedensabkommen mehr gewinnt als weiter
auf einen militärischen Erfolg zu hoffen
einen Krieg zu starten das geht schnell
ihm zu beenden auch das ist eine Lehre
der Geschichte aber kann dauern manchmal
Jahrzehnte
das allerdings wäre verheerend jetzt
noch mal Johanna ja mit einer
erschütternden Nachricht aus den USA bei
einem schusswaffenangriff in einem
Nachtclub in der Stadt Colorado Springs
sind fünf Menschen getötet worden 18
weitere wurden verletzt der Club ist vor
allem bei Schulen Lesben und in der
transcommunity beliebt laut Polizei
hatte ein 22-Jähriger kurz nach Betreten
des Lokals das Feuer eröffnet der Mann
sei festgenommen worden die genauen
Hintergründe der Tat sind noch nicht
bekannt
Donald Trump darf wieder twittern der
neue Chef der Plattform Elon Musk hat
den gesperrten Account des
exos-präsidenten wiederhergestellt die
mehrzufuhr die Nutzerinnen und Nutzer
darüber abstimmen ließ Trump hatte erst
vor wenigen Tagen seine erneute
Präsidentschaftskandidatur verkündet ob
er Twitter wieder nutzen wird ist unklar
Anfang 2021 kurz nach der Stürmung des
Kapitols in Washington hat der Twitter
das Profil von Trump gesperrt
Finale in der Formel 1 beim Grand Prix
in Abu Dhabi es war das letzte Rennen
der Saison und das allerletzte für
Sebastian Vettel der erfolgreichste
deutsche Formel 1 Pilot nach Michael
Schumacher trat mit einer soliden
Leistung ab Platz 10 in seinem 299
Rennen ein WM Punkt zum Abschluss auch
für Mick Schumacher heißt es vorläufig
Abschied nehmen seine Zukunft ist
ungewiss Sieger des Rennens Weltmeister
Max Verstappen vor Vize-Weltmeister
Schale Claire und Teamkollege
die eine Woche geht die Nächste kommt
immer gut zu wissen auf was wir da
achten sollten Christian von Rechenberg
nimmt uns mit
[Musik]
am Mittwoch geht es im
Vermittlungsausschuss ums Bürgergeld von
der Ampel beschlossen von der Union
blockiert sie verlangt Änderungen ein
Kompromiss wäre laut Beobachtern möglich
ist aber keinesfalls sicher
lange Jahre hat die Isar keine
Astronauten mehr ausgebildet nun geht's
wieder los knapp 23.000 haben sich
beworben auch 3700 deutsche vielleicht
folgt einer oder eine von ihnen Matthias
Maurer und alexander Gerst ins All
Entscheidung am Mittwoch bei ihrem
letzten Treffen gab es Zoff um den
gaspreisdeckel einigen sich die
Energieminister der EU diesmal auf einen
Höchstpreis für eingekauftes Gas am
Donnerstag ist alles möglich von
Einigkeit bis eh klar
außerdem öffnen nächste Woche die
Weihnachtsmärkte die ersten bereits ab
Montag ab Freitag glitzert und duftet es
dann auch auf dem Nürnberger
Christkindlesmarkt ohne größere
Beschränkungen je nachdem wie es die
Märkte mit Corona und Strom sparen so
halten
und jetzt die ziemlich winterlichen
Wetteraussichten morgen am Vormittag vor
allem in Thüringen und Sachsen Schnee
und gefrierender Regen an der See und im
südostenschauer sonst auch mal Sonne bei
0 bis 11 Grad am Dienstag bei ein bis
zehn Grad an der Nordsee sowie südlich
der Donau Regen in den Alpen viel
Neuschnee danach unbeständig und
allmählich wieder milder viele Neuschnee
das war unser Sonntag im heute journal
vom ganzen Team auch dem hinter den
Kameras danke dass ihr dabei waren und
morgen freuen sich hier Maria Slomka auf
sie und an dieser Stelle Heinz Rolf
[Musik]